a quanti di voi capita ogni giorno di
dover prendere decisioni anche piuttosto
importanti ma di non sapere cosa o come
fare per esempio l'ultima volta che
avete deciso di prendere un regalo a
vostro figlio o alla vostra compagna al
vostro amico come lo avete scelto
o ancora l'ultima volta che avete deciso
di andare in vacanza come avete scelto
la meta e se io vi dicessi che per dare
una risposta a queste domande si può
utilizzare la probabilità prima però di
esporvi tutto il nostro progetto ci
tengo a sottolineare che come ha detto
prima alessia il progetto non riguarda
solo matematica e statistica a primo
acchito infatti può sembrare così però
il concetto che c'è alla base è quello
della democrazia partecipativa
quindi ognuno al diritto ma soprattutto
il dovere e quindi anche un obbligo
morale di intervenire esprimere la
propria opinione e quindi prendere la
decisione più utile per la comunità
ciò avviene anche nel nostro progetto
infatti come vi mostrerò in seguito
abbiamo utilizzato questo concetto e ci
siamo ispirati diciamo a questo concetto
per far partire tutto siamo andati nelle
casse della nostra scuola a fare un
sondaggio per chi abbiamo fatto questo
perché abbiamo stabilito di avere un
ipotetica somma di denaro da investire
nella scuola quindi come prima cosa era
necessario capire quali aspetti della
vita o dell'ambiente scolastico si
volevano migliorare e chi può sapere ciò
meglio degli studenti che frequentano la
scuola
quindi siamo andati nelle classi del
nostro liceo e abbiamo fatto agli
studenti una semplice domanda cosa
vorreste migliorare nella vostra scuola
è una domanda qui prima o poi tutti gli
studenti in maniera volontaria o meno
rispondono tutti gli studenti prima o
poi dicono eh ma la porta non si chiude
è ma la finestra rotta e ma la cassa è
piena di cimici come accadde tra l'altro
quest'anno quindi tutti gli studenti
avevano un'idea precisa di cosa volevano
migliorare per dar loro modo di
esprimere la propria opinione
oltre chiaramente raccogliere le
impressioni e opinioni in classe abbiamo
creato un gruppo facebook quindi abbiamo
fatto un sondaggio dove gli studenti non
hanno avuto solo la possibilità di
esprimere le proprie opinioni ma anche
quella di votare le altre
terminato questo sondaggio abbiamo
selezionato le opzioni più votate che
erano risultavano essere circa 12
e infine abbiamo stabilito la cifra base
del nostro budget 100 mila euro
cosa facciamo con 100mila euro guardiamo
cosa hanno detto gli studenti
selezioniamo come detto le opzioni più
votate e vediamo per esempio che al
primo posto figura in tutte le classi
ovvero la lavagna interattiva
multimediale stabilito che questo era
uno degli obiettivi che gli studenti
volevano raggiungere tra l'altro è
quello che ha ricevuto il maggior numero
di voti di gran lunga abbiamo cercato in
internet il costo medio di ogni lim in
questo caso risultava essere circa 1.500
euro
fatto ciò abbiamo creato 18 possibili
combinazioni di acquisti ovvero come
potrebbe essere 50 lim tre bagni inteso
3 ristrutturazioni dei bagni e 80 banchi
o dieci bagni una nuova aula professore
due palestre
non ho scritto tutte le 18 combinazioni
perché risulterebbe noioso da leggere
però ci tengo a precisare che il numero
18 può sembrare magari ragionato o meno
in realtà è un numero completamente
casuale in classe l'anno scorso eravamo
in 18 quindi abbiamo scelto di fare un
opzione a testa in maniera da
coinvolgere tutta la classe come abbiamo
realizzato nel nostro progetto
utilizzando una rete bayesiana il
termine bayesiano deriva dagli studi in
campo probabilistico di thomas bass
matematico vissuto in gran bretagna time
1602 e il 1661 se la rete bayesiana è un
modello grafico che combinato con le
probabilità che inseriamo noi
all'interno dei nodi che in questo caso
come vedete in figura sono i cerchi e
grazie a rapporti di dipendenza tra uno
dell'altro che in questo caso indicato
dalle frecce permette di semplificare un
problema complesso come vedrete in
seguito può essere la scelta diciamo
l'opzione migliore per migliorare la
nostra scuola
vedete che sotto la prima colonna di
cerchi c'è scritto obiettivi primario
vengono di genitori
questi nuovi genitori invece si
differenziano dagli altri che vedete si
chiamano di figli perché hanno una
peculiarità come vedete le frecce
partono esclusivamente dai diode i
genitori e arrivano ai figli ma non ci
sono frecce che arrivano i nodi genitori
cosa significa ciò
pieno di genitori inserita una
determinata probabilità influenzeranno i
nodi successivi però non vengono
infettati da nulla quindi sono un po le
radici del nostro progetto
se andiamo a vedere la seconda colonna
quella degli obiettivi intermedi
chiamati anche noi di figli
notiamo che oltre ad avere frecce che
partono dai nodi figli
e arrivano ai miei figli del livello
successivo abbiamo anche lendl e le
frecce che giungono dai nuovi genitori
ciò significa che se andiamo a vedere
per esempio l'ultimo l'ultimo scalino
che è quello degli obiettivi finali
vediamo che ci sono frecce che giungono
dai nodi figli del livello prima del
livello prima ancora è da lettere cileno
di genitori quindi cosa significa ciò in
parole povere povere mica tanto si
arriva a dedurre che i valori che
troveremo all'interno degli obiettivi
finali sono diciamo risultato della
combinazione del rapporto genitore
figlio quindi più livelli avremo come
vediamo nella nostra età abbiamo circa
sette livelli più questi valori saranno
anche simili tra loro oppure molto
diversi
vedete che dopo gli obiettivi finali è
presente un ovale in cui c'è scritto
valore finale e si tratta di un numero
in valore assoluto come potrebbe essere
per esempio 44 che indica l'utilità del
dell'opzione scelta in percentuale
quindi 44 corrisponde a 44 per cento
chiaramente questo valore in che cosa ci
indica selezione è buona o meno più è
alto più l'opzione vantaggiosa come
vedrete come vi mostrerò dopo più
selezionando opzioni diverse il
risultato cambia stabilito con cosa
utilizzare la nostra con come realizzare
il nostro progetto è stata però
necessaria un'attività di brainstorming
quindi per cercare di capire oltre agli
obiettivi che si volevano realizzare e
quindi gli obiettivi che diciamo erano
il top che volevamo realizzare
assolutamente che sono risultati essere
il benessere degli studenti e quindi in
sottointeso l'aumento la sicurezza e il
successo formativo che è abbastanza
importante quindi abbiamo fatto un
attività di brainstorming per capire gli
obiettivi che dovevano esserci in mezzo
e in che maniera si collegavano come
potete vedere è molto ordinato
si capisce poco però noi da questo lo
abbiamo semplificato ulteriormente
rendendolo molto leggibile per quanto
sembra è molto carina molto d'impatto
però bisogna imparare a leggere questa
tabella e ora vi spiego come abbiamo
chiamato gli elementi della colonna ha
gli elementi della riga b per indicare
il rapporto di dipendenza di a dhabi
cioè prendiamo per esempio
l'apprendimento è il primo elemento
della colonna
be se vogliamo indicare il rapporto di
dipendenza di a dhabi abbiamo utilizzato
il numero meno uno in questo caso lo
vedete nella casella verde
viceversa se vogliamo indicare il
rapporto di influenza di a subìre ci
serviamo del numero uno utilizzato tutti
scusate utilizzando la casella gialla
abbiamo però riscontrato un caso
particolare come vedete che anche quello
forse un po più numeroso che è quello
della casella fucsia dove all'interno vi
è il più o meno uno cosa vuol dire che
all'interno c'è il più o meno uno
semplicemente che è la porta è duplice
ovvero ha influenza b ma anche di
influenza
facciamo un esempio l'interesse per le
elezioni terzo elemento della colonna e
l'apprendimento
secondo elemento della riga come vedete
il numero che vi all'interno è più o
meno uno
in che modo secondo noi supponiamo che
aumenti l'interesse per le elezioni
magari l'insegnante inizia a spiegare
meglio o con nuovi metodi lo studente si
appassiona magari alla materia e quindi
l'apprendimento dello studente cosa fa
sale guardiamo il caso opposto invece è
possibile che uno studente si metta di
buona volontà a studiare una determinata
materia e che poi si renda conto e dica
ha però mi piace la materia quindi la
studia con più gusto
quindi il suo apprendimento e
sull'interesse migliora in questo modo
abbiamo letto tutte le dodici delle
nazioni che vi sono sono un po diciamo
anche balorde perché potrebbero non
apparire al primo impatto però ci sono
per realizzare la rete bayesiana abbiamo
utilizzato un software realizzato
dall'università di pittsburgh chiamato
gini mentre la matrice come tutto resta
del nostro progetto
lo ha realizzato insieme alla mia classe
che oggi è qui presente a vedermi
ecco la collaborazione di un dirigente
di ricerca del cnr di milano del dottor
ruggeri il progetto è stato svolto
nell'ambito di alternanza scuola lavoro
ea possiamo dire che ha portato via
molte delle nostre ore più che
scolastiche extra scolastiche un
semplice esempio perché un semplice
esempio perché abbiamo preso in mano la
tabella doppia entrata su excel
abbiamo provato a inserire le
probabilità su gini e ci siamo resi
conto che non siamo capaci
quindi abbiamo fatto un piccolo
esercizio per imparare in cui abbiamo
provato a rispondere una domanda molto
frequente soprattutto d'estate dove vado
in vacanza
stabilite le quattro mete più utilizzate
più gettonate dagli italiani ovvero mare
montagna città d'arte estero abbiamo
cercato di capire anche gli elementi che
entrano in gioco quando si sceglie una
determinata destinazione per esempio chi
ovvero la compagnia secondo amici
genitori chiaramente congenito riteniamo
anche famiglia perché un quarantenne non
va in vacanza con la madre non si spera
la durata se maggiori e minori di sette
giorni
l'agenzia quindi se utilizzarlo o meno
il mezzo per via terra per via aerea
essendo il traghetto molto poco usato
non abbiamo tenuto conto il costo
stimato in media maggior minori di mille
e la soddisfazione cioè se alla fine
della vacanza se ha voglia di tornare lì
infine vediamo che abbiamo il valore
totale che è quello che ho detto prima e
dell'utilità attesa che è del 62 65 per
cento
ciò per quanto possa sembrare una
probabilità appena sopra la media è
molto significativo vuol dire che
andando al mare la propria di rimanere
soddisfatti è del 62 per cento
sempre meglio di niente se guardiamo le
altre mani e invece abbiamo il valore
totale che è diventato 62,36 perché
perché l'opzione che abbiamo selezionati
diversa via e l'estero e vedete anche
che le probabilità all'interno dei vari
nodi sono tutte differenti
l'unico nodo che fa eccezione è il nodo
del costo ma si tratta di una pura
casualità
quindi se mare e vuol dire 62,6 per
cento di soddisfazione e estero
se sono 2,3 cosa ne capiamo che la rete
ha deciso che noi dobbiamo andare in
vacanza al mare
chiaramente si tratta di un consiglio
che potete seguire o meno un po come
quello della mamma l'unica differenza è
che la rete non vi pice se non lo
seguite terminato questo esempio posso
mostrarvi finalmente la nostra rete
definitiva che è quella grande immagine
a sinistra dove nel rettangolo giallo vi
sono le 18 possibili combinazioni di
acquisti al primo livello vi sono i
dodicenni tori poi tutti i vari nodi
figli come vedete i livelli sono tanti e
poi c'è una particolarità i tre
obiettivi finali in realtà sono quelle
di chi ha un colore più o meno simile al
rosso e poi convergono tutti verso un
ulteriore nodo questo perché perché
abbiamo capito che aumentando come detto
prima il benessere la sicurezza è
successo fronti o degli studenti
sarebbero aumentate anche le iscrizioni
come anche lo ciò che si ha
quindi l'abbiamo messo sotto come
obiettivo possiamo dire sintesi di tutte
e tre
il valore che vedete sotto il valore e
utilità attesa e in alto a destra vedete
la struttura esterna di un nodo in
questo caso le certificazioni
linguistiche ovvero ci siamo occupati di
capire come una determinata scelta
avrebbe influenzato il successo o
l'insuccesso degli studenti in questo
campo
se guardate invece sotto vedete una
struttura una tabella che vi spiega come
si fa a dare delle probabilità o meglio
ve lo spiego io come si fa andare
siccome da noi le certificazioni
linguistiche penso per esempio al first
spengono di pomeriggio abbiamo stabilito
che dipendevano il successo o
l'insuccesso di certificazioni generale
dipendeva dall'aumento dall'apertura
dall'aumento della diminuzione delle
aperture pomeridiane
la cosa altra influenza il successo
ol'insuccesso chiaramente
l'apprendimento poteva esserci anche
l'interesse per le elezioni però sarebbe
risultato essere un po complicato in
quel punto quindi l'abbiamo tolto se
consideriamo che aumenta l'apertura
pomeridiana
le aperture pomeridiane e
l'apprendimento secondo me la
probabilità di successo è dell 85 per
cento il valore da 5 per cento non è
dato da una singola persona ma è il
risultato di una media aritmetica tra 18
differenti probabilità perché in classe
ognuno aveva data una e quindi per
rendere tutto più eco possibile abbiamo
uccide tisato se invece guardiamo che le
aperture pomeridiane aumentano però
peggiora l'apprendimento la probabilità
scende a 0 4 quindi 40 per cento
voi direte però sono quattro probabilità
la cia è difficile in questo progetto
tutto perché se vai se andate a vedere
adesso non si vede dalla rete perché
purtroppo le immagini sono queste il
nodo delle certificazioni linguistiche è
più o meno al quinto livello
e vi chiedo di focalizzare la vostra
attenzione sull'immagine in altro e
sulle due freccette che vedete il
convergono verso le certificazioni sono
due
ciò significa che le probabilità da dare
sono due alla seconda cioè 4 dare 4
probabilità è semplice ci pensi un
attimo e poi inserisci guardate un
attimo nodo delle iscrizioni c'è una
freccia nascosta tra l'altro quindi le
probabilità che le frecce che giungono
verso iscrizioni sono sei
quindi le probabilità dare quante sono
due è la sesta 64 dare 64 probabilità
tenendo conto di tutte le piccole
sfumature tutti e piccole differenze è
una cosa molto diversa e ascolto pari a
partire un video si
qui vedete come si fa a utilizzare la
nostra rete selezioniamo un'opzione per
esempio una caso la terza e aggiorniamo
la rete i valori che notate nei doni
sono determinati e l'utilità attese
circa 64,2
cambiamo opzione mettiamo l'opzione
numero 5 e cosa notiamo che aggiornando
nuovamente la rete rimane tutte
differente il valore in questo caso è
sceso al 55 per cento
terminata la nostra rete bayesiana
abbiamo notato che l'opzione migliore
quella peggiore erano la terza e la
quinta che guarda caso sono anche quelle
che abbiamo mostrato nel video e che
come vedete la terza era molto vicina
alla tredicesima però come detto quando
le probabilità e da dare sono tante
anche le opzioni quindi sono 18 sono
comunque tante anche una minima
differenza conta mentre la quinta
diciamo le province abbastanza
nettamente perché si compone chance in a
una utilità se così vogliamo chiamarla
del 55 per cento
queste sono le opzioni in questione
l'opzione migliore l'opzione peggiore e
magari qualcuno di voi adesso si chiede
ma perché proprio queste due opzioni
sono la migliore la peggiore non è non
sono in grado di spiegarlo semplicemente
perché dovreste conoscere la scuola e
problemi che magari a gli studenti che
hanno dato le loro opinioni e
soprattutto noi classe che per quanto è
abbiamo influenzato maggiormente il
progetto però non è stato neanche che
capiate assolutamente perché queste
queste diciamo opzioni sono le migliori
perché quello che abbia mostrato oggi è
solo un piccolo esempio di come
utilizzare la probabilità per dare una
risposta alcune domande per esempio
quando vi trovate di fronte a una scelta
potreste usare la probabilità anziché
l'istinto e pertanto o capire in
anticipo quali conseguenze quella
determinata scelta avrà non solo
nell'immediato ma anche nel futuro
ovvio non mi aspetto che da domani
quando siete al bar o al ristorante
dovete scegliere cosa ordinare
l'immediata questione rete bayesiana ci
mancherebbe però mi piacerebbe che
magari quando vi trovate davanti a un
big davanti a una decisione o un
indecisione per meglio dire vi
ricordiate che c'è questo nuovo metodo
che spero vi rimanga impressa dopo oggi
che è quello della matematica ma molti
di voi si chiedono sicuramente che lo
ammettano o meno perché
ci ha detto tutto questo perché ci hai
parlato di tutti questi nodi tutti
queste frecce e tutti questi valori di
probabilità complicati semplice perché
se a scuola la matematica ci complica la
vita ci dà problemi insufficienze debiti
bocciature nella realtà quotidiana
la matematica la vita ce l'ha semplifica
grazie